now the state coveted response director
wants all of us to remain
vigilant heading into christmas and new
year's health leaders want us to stay
safe so our hospitals don't get
overwhelmed
80s now reporter sally jaramillo live in
the newsroom with more on this sally
david state of nevada kobe 19 response
director caleb cage said they expect to
see what dr
fauci calls a search upon a surge when
people gather that don't live in the
same household there is opportunity for
spread
so with an increase of cases comes an
increase in hospitalizations and
possibly deaths
health bureau chief candice mcdaniel
also joined the cause she gave an update
on vaccinations as of today
the state has received 31 200 doses of
pfizer vaccine
as of tuesday 940 doses of moderna have
been administered
despite the start of vaccinations with
holidays upon us
the state expects our system to be
challenged
according to the nevada hospital
association or nha
nevada nevada's continuing continuous
case increase
uh increases have now been arrested for
approximately 10 days
this indicates that any increased
hospitalizations as a result
of the family day and thanksgiving
holidays has been fully realized
also now it takes about two weeks for us
to see that in the data so we'd expect
to see that in mid to early january
keep in mind several weeks after cases
come to light
is when hospitalizations increase as
well as deaths
so health leaders again asking the
community to avoid the holiday
gatherings this year
and continue to wear your masks live in
the newsroom sally jaramillo 8 news now